une maladie rare c'est une maladie qui
atteint -2 1 en 2002 la population et la
grande majorité sont des maladies
génétiques
on estime qu'il y a plus que 7000
maladies rares moi je me concentre
surtout sur les déficits immunitaires
génétique pour lequel il ya quand même
355 et la liste continue à agrandir les
patients qui arrivent pour mon la
révolution avec moi malheureusement ils
sont un petit peu désespérés ils ont eu
une odyssée diagnostic qui durent des
années ou moins haut ou même plusieurs
années des décennies des années sans
avoir un diagnostic pourquoi ils sont
toujours pas mal
[Musique]
c'est difficile comme médecin est aussi
comme un humain d'avoir quelqu'un qui
est malade devant moi on reconnaît qu'il
ya un problème mais on ne sait pas c'est
quoi exactement la cause la
prononciation que c'est difficile des
patients que je suis dans la clinique on
estime qu on a trouvé un diagnostic d'un
e dans à peu près 15 % seulement 15%
mais quand même 15 % qui n'auraient pas
eu un diagnostic s'y étaient pas venus
chez nous après il ya plusieurs raisons
pourquoi les personnes avec des maladies
rares sont sous diagnostiqué un ça se
peut que notre système de santé est un
petit peu fractionné dans les maladies
rares sont peu connus dans les comités
public d'un comité médical mais aussi on
est tellement surspécialisés que vous
avez mentionné que ça arrive on se
concentre sur un organe est quelqu'un
qui se présente avec un manifestation de
notre gamme pullman et on voit pas
seulement savoir comme impunément la
queue voudrais savoir ce qui arrive avec
les poumons ou un gastro entérologue
sierre avec les intestins nous on veut
savoir tout ce qui se passe parce que
c'est important et éventuellement pour
l'établissement la du profil génotypés
plus grande majorité de leur vie se sont
fait dire que c'était dans leur tête ou
que c'était il avait rien parce qu'on
trouvait rien mais nous c'est vraiment
ce qu'on prend le temps de leur
expliquer c'est pas que vous avez rien
mais on n'a pas encore trouvé
alors les problèmes avec les déficits
immunitaires génétique c'est que ça
affecte le système immunitaire dans ça
peut se présenter un petit peuvent très
très variés en fait ça peut se présenter
avec des infections ou des conditions
automnales à plusieurs sortes de
présentation qui mélange le
l'investigation et notamment salle les
formes en a deux qui sont des tyrans qui
les forment un enfant nuit veulent
participer au protocole de recherche
pour qu'éventuellement on est une
réponse parce que quand on a la réponse
même sont des fois y'a pas de traitement
c'est vraiment un soulagement qui est
qui c'est assez important
notre programme pour les déficits
immunitaires génétique vraiment à deux
grandes parties la partie clinique qu'on
était un arbre lequel je travaillais
avec mélanie là qu'est notre laboratoire
de recherche afin de leur donner une
réponse comme très strict des
diagnostics ont pu essayer de prévenir
les infections que ce soit un gros
impact sur leur qualité de vie on n'est
pas un manque de patience ça c'est sûr
et certain on appelait le patient avec
des maladresses ou non diagnostiquée
mais pour aller plus loin pour
poursuivre un diagnostic il faut avoir
des fonds de ressources il faut avoir
des capacités pour engager des gens à
utiliser des instruments acheter des
réactifs on a besoin de tout ça qui
malheureusement ça fait pas partie de
notre plan national qu'est ce que je
souhaite c'est que y'a aucun patient
avec une maladie rare qui restent non
diagnostiqué une entrée t
[Musique]